[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
an arkansas mother says she spoke to her
daughter's accused killer
while they were still out looking for
her cindy sutherland's mother
calling for justice and the death
penalty she just was a
beautiful person inside and out
the minnesota court of appeals ruling
the trial judge was wrong in refusing to
reinstate
third degree murder for one of the
ex-cops in the death of george floyd
why derrick shobin is not yet facing a
third charge just days before jury
selection
is set to begin plus the tennessee task
force who recovered 150 missing children
how investigators were able to track
down missing kids across state lines
and the couple who met the donor
recipient of their son's heart
the tears the heartbeats a courthouse
wedding unlike any other
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the family of a slain arkansas jogger is
speaking out after an accused murder was
deemed competent to stand trial
sydney sutherland's mother and brothers
tell me that their lives have changed
forever
since the loss of their beloved sydney
and they plan to attend
every single day of the trial of her
accused killer
sydney um was just a beautiful
big brown eyes right smile a heart
of giving loving caring maggie
sutherland
says her daughter sydney had a bright
future at 25 years old
sydney was working as a nurse in
arkansas we had just got back
um the night before between nine and ten
we had been
on a family vacation to florida so the
next day
um i had just got a normal routine of
unloading and
putting away and everything and about 10
30 she come by the house and she had a
workout clothes on and she
i said where you been she said well
we've been gone all week and
i just feel like i need to work out
sydney left her family's home to go
jogging on august 19
2020 later that day her boyfriend called
maggie
unable to find her or get her on the
phone he just said
something's not right sydney's not here
sydney's car and belongings were at
home so her family reported her as
missing to law enforcement
by nightfall more than a hundred people
were out
searching for her i immediately got on
the phone with atnt
trying to locate her phone that was very
difficult because
that's um that didn't happen very easily
maggie says one man stood out to her
quake llewellyn
he was the last to see sydney out
running i said
can you not tell me anything like where
she was at or anything
he goes no she was just running and then
he just went and got some food and
walked off police brought llewellyn
in for questioning they say he confessed
to hitting sydney with his truck
putting her in his vehicle raping her
and then burying her body
i think they looked at the 360 on his
phone and showed
that he was in a general area and i
think that's how they pinpoint where her
body
could have been and ultimately that's
where they found her body yeah
llewellyn is charged with murder
kidnapping rape and abuse of a corpse
he's pleaded not guilty his trial is set
for this september
her family says they plan to be there
for every moment
we're gonna sit there and watch listen
and just wait till we get the justice
for sydney
we believe you know the death penalty
would be the best
to get the justice for sydney that we we
want you know
we don't want him to be able to sit in
prison the rest of his life
he took our my daughter their sister
our sassy our friend for no reason
and brutally did things to her that was
just
something that we have to live with
every day
um for him just to be able to sit in
jail and breathe and
get food and everything but just one day
he just took her life for no reason
it's hard to say that you want someone
to have the death but when they've done
that to
your baby it's it's hard
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi gene as a former
prosecutor what did you make of this
alleged confession
that llewelyn thought sydney sutherland
was dead before any sexual acts occurred
maybe beating a top count i don't know
what do you think
i'm now a criminal defense attorney
after being a prosecutor for almost 30
years
and all i can say is is that the defense
attorney may have let his guard down
if your if your client has been accused
or could be accused of
murder premeditated rape and killing
you don't have him talk to the police
under any circumstances
he has a right against
self-incrimination i don't know what
happened but they had a meeting
the attorney was there he let his client
make incredibly
inculpatory admissions and statements to
the police
and for my understanding they can be
used against them at trial
there's no protection there is some
protection when you're doing plea
negotiations
but here there doesn't seem to be any
protection
against using his statements against
them in the government's case in chief
exactly now terry powerful interview
when you spoke with cindy's mother and
uh family there what was it that you
felt she wanted the world to know about
her daughter
brian i think they want the world to
know that she was a loving daughter she
was a loving sister she was a loving
aunt she was a nurse and she cared about
people
they even called her sassy and the
nieces called her
aunt sassy and they called her that
because she was spoiled as a little girl
because she was the only girl in the
family
so i think they want the public to
remember who she is
and they want to thank the public for
doing all that they did to
find her so i think that at the end of
the day they want justice
and they are hoping that they get
justice and that in fact the death
penalty is imposed here
so not to sit in jail for the rest of
his life but to actually make sure that
he's punished for this horrible brutal
crime
yeah when you put together as gene was
saying that interview
with the police and the allegations of
running her
over raping her then bearing her body
this is not the case that i think he's
going to be spared from the death
penalty
it's going to be a tough uphill battle
for the defense but well of course
we'll keep eyes on this case thank you
both still ahead on law and crime daily
amber geiger's appeal is arguing what
she is and is not guilty of
in the murder of botham jean but first
the minnesota court of appeals rules
against derek shovin in the george ford
murder case
but what does that mean for the trial
that's next
[Music]
we're back right on the heels of the
trial of the first ex-cop charge for the
death of george floyd the minnesota
court of appeals rules the trial judge
aired derek chovin is facing charges of
second degree murder
and second degree manslaughter chova's
defense convinced the trial judge to
drop the charge of third degree murder
since then the appeals court upheld the
same charge for former minneapolis cop
mohammad noor
noor was convicted in the 2017 shooting
of an australian-american woman who
called police to report a possible
assault
now the appeals court is ruling the
judge made a mistake in not reinstating
the third degree murder charge against
chauvin
this doesn't reinstate the charge but
instead sends the argument back to the
trial judge for reconsideration
the court says its presidential opinion
became binding authority
on the day it was filed ruling against
the defense
i would generally agree that yes you
could be potentially faced with a
situation
where a court of appeals issues a
precedential opinion
and that opinion does not take effect
for
12 plus months as the court points out
but it
also ignores when the state says that
there is no
harm to a defendant especially in the
context of a criminal case
so you look at you look at the context
of a criminal case
yes my client would have the right to
appeal that decision if nor were to be
overturned
but he would have to do it from the
confines of a prison cell
and that is volatile of due process
and it's astonishing to me what my
friend just said
to to joshua in response he said well
the remedy for the state
is in other cases just not to charge
homicides for a year
or longer imagine the harm to the public
not just obviously in a case like this
with the gravity
it has but in any case to say
prosecutors have to wait
a year or more to bring homicide charges
that can't
possibly be the law and indeed one
reason why starry decisis binds trial
courts
is because of equality that's something
that i think all three of you were
getting at
in your questions to my friend like
cases can't be treated unlike
the family of victims of police
brutality and activists came together
before the trial
to call for reforms before you what you
see
is a scroll of names of people who have
been killed by law enforcement in the
state of minnesota
five of the names on this scroll belong
to derrick shovin
[Music]
the city of minneapolis failed time and
again to hold him accountable
and because they failed to hold him
accountable because they failed
to have policies in place that would
end his reign of terror because of these
things
they created the conditions that allowed
george floyd to be killed
here to discuss the court of appeals
decision and the upcoming trial of derek
shovin
is former federal prosecutor gene rossi
and terry austin
terry why do you think getting this
charge against shogun was so important
to the prosecution
well brian it gives the prosecution
another option remember we already have
second-degree murder here where he was
charged with committing this crime
while he was doing third degree assault
and so we also have a manslaughter
charge and you know for that charge it's
really
creating negligence and causing an
unreasonable risk
but with this third degree charge and
third degree murder here
will see that they can also prove that
he was acting with a depraved mind and
without regard to
human life and it's 25 years so it gives
the jury
an entirely another option if they don't
think that this was
you know committed while he was doing an
assault or they don't think it was
reckless this is a great option for the
prosecution
makes sense now gene you've been here
before in terms of the procedure of this
case
the court of appeals has sent the
decision for murder in the third degree
to be reconsidered by the trial judge so
what's next
well it's going to go back to the trial
court judge
and if he doesn't add that third degree
count and i agree with terry
it does change the dynamics of the trial
because it increases the chances of
conviction
i think if the judge does not add that
trial and file
and follow that nor opinion uh then they
may go up again on an
interlocutory appeal but i think the
trial judge is going to uh
understand that he just got a hand check
like in basketball
and he's going to add that third count
and this will greatly enhance the
prosecution's case
and i would never disagree with neil
cottyah
who is uh is one of the most brilliant
people who ever worked at the justice
department
it's kind of interesting to see how this
plays out because of course if they do
add that charge as i think most people
believe it's going to happen
court of appeals tells the trial judge
what to do they usually do it
what's the defense going to do they
could possibly appeal it themselves
push it back ask for more time because
hey there's a whole new charge
it's going to be very interesting to see
how this plays out and when it plays out
but to figure that out be sure to tune
in to the law and crime network for
gavel to gavel coverage of children's
trial
starting march 8. coming up on law on
crime daily an update on convicted
murderer amber geiger
the appeal that's raising more than a
few eyebrows plus
a courthouse wedding unlike any other
the surprise one family received
after the break
welcome back some may think a wedding at
a courthouse
might not be the most heartfelt but as
long crime founder and the host of the a
e series court camp
dan abrams tells us it was exactly that
for one texas family
next we head to a montgomery county
justice of the peace courtroom in willis
texas
where friends and family are gathering
for the wedding celebration of long-time
couple
monica morrison and dean birkenoff
joining them are their two children
therefore along with judge wayne mack
who's officiating
dean and monica today is the beginning
of your continuing life together
it looks just like any ordinary
courthouse wedding
but what the happy couple doesn't know
is that their special day is about to
take a huge left turn
before i pronounce them is there anybody
here that would like to raise an
objection
i would and i love both of you so very
much
and i know the one thing in the world
that you both would want so much is to
have cold in here
[Music]
colton was monica and dean's other son
who suddenly passed away seven years ago
it was a devastating time for the family
but they found some comfort in donating
colton's organs to those in need
and i know the one thing in the world
that you both would want so much
is to have colt in here
this is 28 year old travis stufflebee
he's an organ recipient and he's alive
today
because inside his chest
he's here colton's heart beats on
and this is the first time the couple
and travis have
ever come face to face
travis wanted to be here because
brought a stethoscope
i would like you to have the opportunity
it's cold
yeah i'm just borrowing it and to me
this is where i belong
and thank you from my family
to you guys like we were grateful
and the heart is finally home
[Applause]
it's my honor and privilege today to
pronounce you man and what
dean let me greet you brian
i don't think there is any words it was
special special to hear them again
that was um absolutely beautiful um
can't say anything more about that when
we come back operation volunteers strong
out of the volunteer estate
saves dozens of children the law
enforcement mission you don't want to
miss
welcome back a former dallas police
officer convicted of killing a man in
his own home
will ask a judge to overturn her 10-year
sentence next month
jesse weber is here to tell us about the
amber geiger case on his new show
prime crime yeah hey there brian this is
a police shooting really unlike
anything else we're talking about the
amber geiger case that former dallas
officer who
shot and killed her unarmed neighbor
botham jean inside his very own
apartment
now why exactly did this happen while we
examined the 911 phone call that was
placed right after the shooting
the body cam footage as officers raced
to the scene and we hear
from the shooter herself and i yelled at
him it's like let me see
your hands let me see your hands he
started coming towards me
how fast was he coming towards you a
fast-paced walk
i thought he was coming back i couldn't
see his hands he was gonna kill me
did you hear anything as he was walking
towards you
he there was a lot of yell he was
yelling hey hey
hey an aggressive voice and that's at
that point whenever i
shot and what geiger's legal team is up
to now may make you think twice
about this defendant tune in to law and
crime
thanks jesse 150 missing children are
now
safe thanks to the joint law enforcement
mission in tennessee
operation volunteer strong since the
fall of 2020 the u.s marshals service
has been working alongside
the tennessee department of children's
services and bureau of investigation
the joint task force identified 240
missing children
then developed leads through
intelligence analysis agents found 150
of those missing children
with ages ranging from 3 to 17 years old
this child had been missing for 460 days
that this child had been missing and you
know no one may not be charged in this
case
but can you imagine being that child and
knowing
not knowing after 460 days whether
somebody was really looking for him or
not
we also made a number of arrests during
this operation including the
coincidental apprehension
of tiffany moore who was wanted for
attempted carjacking in memphis
our search was not limited by state
lines
wisconsin law enforcement assisted us in
recovering a
brownsville boy in their state
and also a missing girl from memphis was
recovered in georgia
additionally we located a missing girl
from iowa
in a motel in horn lake mississippi
about 18 miles outside of memphis there
were indications of human trafficking
and that's an ongoing investigation by
the horn lake
police department and fbi we also found
a missing nebraska girl
in a dyersburg motel the man she was
with
austin swatter he was wanted on a
nebraska warrant
for terroristic threats and unlawful use
of a firearm to commit a felony
it was our pleasure to help him find his
way back to the cornhusker state
here to discuss operation volunteer
strong is gene rossi and terry austin
gene the number of how many children
we're missing is just
staggering how do you coordinate such an
operation
i did that when i was an assistant u.s
attorney
when you have an operation as big as
this volunteer strong
you have the united states marshal of
tennessee bureau of investigation
the fbi and probably uh four or five
other federal and state agencies
and you work as a team and esprit de
corps and it
involves a lot of man and woman power it
is an incredibly
uh thrilling effort and they had
incredible results
but involved search warrants of of cell
phone data
emails homes but i'm so happy
and he brought up a good point the first
speaker that there may not be charges
but there are a lot of happy people
mothers
dads uh family friends who are just
grateful that those 150 were recovered
now don't bear in mind there there are
probably about 90 who have not been
recovered but identified
and that that's a sad thing if they
can't find those others
absolutely now terry rescuing is only
half of the battle what's going to
happen
to those children that were found well
the objective really is to put them back
into their homes as
quickly as possible but in the short
term the state has to do an assessment
to make sure that the homes are suitable
and what will happen is that the
tennessee department of children's
services
will in the interim take care of them
either in foster care or group homes
until they can make sure that they have
a home where these children can be sent
on a more permanent basis
let's hope that this current pandemic or
just
life in general is not stopping or
delaying that process
gene terry thank you and thank you for
joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you